[Music]
google cloud recently announced the new
postgresql interface for cloud spanner
this combines the power and reliability
of spanner with the familiarity of
postgres
postgres is a well-established open
source database with a vibrant and
growing ecosystem that many development
and ops teams are already familiar with
the postgres interface allows
organizations to take advantage of
google's managed relational database
using standard tools and skills from the
postgres ecosystem
the interface supports spanner's rich
feature set as well as common postgres
data types and sql syntax
in this video i will show you how easy
it is to set up a spanner database with
the postgresql interface
then integrate that into a python
application using the open source
spanner client library and finally i'll
use the standard postgres psql command
line tool to explore the database
first let's create a new spanner
instance using the cloud console
i'm creating a small instance for this
test with spanner's granular instant
sizing i can easily scale that up later
as needed without downtime or
re-architecture
a spanner instance can host multiple
databases
if you already have an existing spanner
instance you will need to create a new
database with the postgres dialect
support
when i create a database i can choose
between google standard sql and
postgresql as the dialect
i'll select the postgresql option
both dialects support the same set of
capabilities
it's important to mention that the
postgres interface does not implement
all of postgres sql functionality
rather it provides postgres syntax for
existing spanner features to avoid
having to learn new semantics when you
begin using spanner
so next i will create a users table
i'll use postgres ddl and data types
because it's just postgres the schema
change would run the same in any other
postgres environment
so this makes applications written
against the postgres interface more
portable
it's worth mentioning that you can use
the gcloud command line tool to create
the database if you prefer just make
sure to specify the database dialect
option
leveraging one of the supported spanner
drivers you can start writing
applications against the database we
just created right away
besides the spanner client library no
additional software is needed
for example
we have a python application here that
connects to our database and leverages
the postgresql interface
i've downloaded the spanner python
client library and installed it via pip
into my virtual environment
in this simple application i import the
library and define the instance and
database
then i issue an insert into our users
table using familiar postgres syntax
for instance i'm not having to specify a
column list like i would with spanner's
dialect
you'll also notice that i use the
postgres now function to populate the
timestamp columns rather than the
current timestamp function available in
spanner's default sql dialect
i just showed how we could use the
native spanner driver to run postgres
syntax sql from a python application but
what about other tools like psql that
don't know anything about spanner
for those we've provided a proxy called
the pg adapter that translates the
postgres wire protocol into spanner's
own grpc based protocol
to set it up you will need to
authenticate with the gcloud command
line tool to generate the credentials
required to connect to your spanner
instance
then download the pg adapter jar file
and run it that's it
with pg adapter running the only thing
left is to connect with psql
i can use psql syntax to list out the
tables
now i can create a unique index on the
email field in our users table again
leveraging postgres syntax
next i want to query the information
schema
you can see that the postgres data types
are displayed for the columns
initially pgadapter is only provided for
development scenarios with psql but we'd
like to support a broader range of
postgres tools eventually
so that's how easy it is to set up a
spanner instance with the new postgresql
interface and get started using it in
your application and with psql
if you want google's highly available
and scalable managed relational database
and already know postgres sql syntax
this is for you
the postgresql interface for spanner is
now available for preview
you can sign up for the preview by
filling out the form in the description
below
go ahead and try it out and let us know
what you think in the comments
you